if you're looking for an exercise that
make you look and feel like an absolute
badass then what better place to look
than to a real life badass jack lalanne
of all of these slightly showy moves i
perform on this channel and i mean at
this point i'm practically a performing
monkey there's one that gets more
comments than any other without fail
that being the la land push-up also
called the superman push-up and it's no
surprise because it's slightly less
common than some of the other cool moves
you might see like handstand push-ups or
what have you at the same time though it
still has that awesome gravity-defying
aesthetic that just looks cool by nature
but it's not just a neat party trick the
la lamp push-up is actually a really
powerful exercise to have in your
arsenal that trains so much so in this
video i'm going to explain how and why
you should be doing the land push-up and
why it's awesome
by the way check out the grass around
here this is meant to be green but we've
had multiple heat waves here in the uk
it's a bit unprecedented looks like a
post-apocalyptic wasteland around here
the leland push-up was of course made
famous by a guy called jack lalanne jack
leland is sometimes called the godfather
of modern fitness and he's remembered
for many of his insane feats of strength
he did things like swimming the length
of the san francisco golden gate bridge
and water whilst carrying 140 pounds of
equipment he performed 1 000 push-ups in
just 23 minutes aged 42 and even more
amazing he once did a thousand push-ups
and 1 000 chin-ups in just 82 minutes on
his show the jacqueline show
reportedly jack came up with this
specific movement the la lamp push-up
when he was asked to demonstrate for
someone a finger push-up and he thought
this was too easy so instead he extended
his arms out in front of him and the
rest as they say is history however it's
worth noting that lalanne probably
wasn't the very first person to do this
you might also call it an extended
push-up and there are examples of it
being used elsewhere prior to jack
lalanne so now i'm going to show you a
little bit about how to perform the lamp
push-up and at the same time i'm going
to talk about why it's such a beneficial
movement but first
so there are lots of good reasons that
the la land push-up is way more than
just a party trick for starters it's
best to think of the leland push-up as
less of a push-up and more of a core
exercise in fact it has more in common
with say a dragon flag or maybe an ab
roll out in particular because what
you're doing here is by stretching your
arms out in front of you you have a
longer torso that you need to maintain
you have a longer lever arm and your job
is to prevent back extension so your
stomach wants to sag and touch the
ground and it's your job to brace the
core and prevent that from happening
thereby keeping yourself nice and rigid
and in doing so you're essentially
maintaining a kind of hollow body
position which is the same kind of
position used for a whole host of
different calisthenics moves advanced
calisthenics moves so if you're
interested in that kind of thing this is
a great exercise for starters at the
same time a rigid core is crucial for
transferring power to the ground
if you do a few of these and you're new
to it then you're going to really feel
this in the abs and the rectus abdominal
the next day
speaking of things that make you look
badass
hi
yeah that's right today my sponsor is
premium lifestyle brand vincero
collective so vincero produces stunning
watches eyewear jewelry and a whole lot
more their products are high quality and
extremely stylish plus they're ethically
made with rigorous quality control right
now vincero are running a sale for their
eighth anniversary that'll net you up to
30 off your entire purchase with all
shipping covered just click the link in
the description box below and go to
vincero collective dot com forward slash
bioneer
they also have a five year guarantee and
365 day free return policy is standard
so there's no risk to you
i don't know if this makes me a model
now
but yes i'm a model now i chose the
chrono s watch in gunmetal and walnut
and the marshall shades in matte black
and the shades i feel make me look like
an 80s action hero which is basically my
style aspirations in a nutshell they're
really eye-catching modern designs they
feel quality and i've already had a few
compliments on them thanks again to
vincero collective for sponsoring this
video and remember you can get thirty
percent off your order right now by
going to vincerocollective.com forward
slash bioneer
and speaking of doing away with the need
for equipment the land push-up is
actually one of the very best ways you
can train your lats without any
equipment at all i'm talking if you have
no pull-up bar nothing to hang from and
no barbell or dumbbells this makes it
very hard to train the lats but actually
the lamp pull-up has something in common
with another exercise that being the
pullover
so when you perform a pullover you have
your arms over your head like this and
you're pulling from the resistance
coming from behind you this engages the
lats that's exactly the same movement
you're using when you perform the lamp
push-up now a few people have asked
whether this might be bad for your
shoulders but the truth is that unless
you have some kind of existing shoulder
problem it should be no issue
whatsoever
whilst you are going to be an extension
with your arms overhead it's no more so
than if you're doing a military press
for example and actually you're not
going to get your arms all the way up by
your ears because your torso is going to
get in the way before you can do that so
now it's pretty safe and actually this
will build your shoulder stability which
is great if you want to perform things
like handstand presses or increase your
strength on the military press it's
great for punching etcetera because of
course you need stability before you can
exert force
at the same time it's also a great
exercise if you want to strengthen your
fingers and the tendons in your hand
this is because it is of course if you
choose to go up on your fingers a finger
push-up a fingertip push-up and think
that push-ups are great for building
that kind of grip strength this one's
actually particularly good for that
because due to the angle you're going to
be pulling on the ground more so which
makes it more of a gripping motion
rather than the force the pressure
coming directly down now of course
performing these on your fingers is
optional the reason we do it is to
actually raise ourselves off the ground
and thereby creating a greater range of
motion however if you want the benefits
but you're worried about your finger
strength being a limiting factor and
preventing you from building more
strength then what you can do is perform
as many on your fingertips as you can
and then drop to your hands to complete
the set when you're finished so to
perform the lamp push up what you're
basically going to do is to get onto the
ground as they're going to perform a
regular push-up but instead of having
your hands by the sides you're still
going to extend them in front of you as
though you were trying to reach for
something on a cupboard
legs out straight as well you're going
to ideally have your fingers on the
ground instead of your palms of your
hands then by hinging at the shoulders
and a little bit at the waist you're
going to push on the ground and you're
going to raise yourself off the ground
like so it's up to you whether you want
to rest on the ground between reps
whether you want to keep yourself
slightly suspended in the air all the
way through
when performing any kind of fingertip
push-up you don't want your fingers to
be digging into the ground straight like
that you don't want them to be bending
at the knuckles like that ideally you
want to have them splayed so you have
the maximum amount of surface area
covering the ground and at the same time
so it spans this knuckle here this is
going to place less pressure on the
joints and at the same time by having a
little bit more surface area on the
ground actually makes the movement a
little bit easier
[Music]
if you find this movement a little bit
difficult and you're looking for an
easier variation then there are a bunch
of obvious options for starters you can
perform the alarm push up on your knees
or you can do ab roll outs on your knees
alternatively of course you can just
bring your arms in a little bit closer
that's another easier variation you can
build up the strength with things like
the pull over like the dragon flag or
even just hollow body holds to get to
that point where you're capable of more
easily performing this exercise another
easier variation of course is a walkout
instead of a roll out simply stand with
your legs together bend straight down
place your hands on the floor and then
walk yourself out until you reach that
stretched out the land position of
course this is great as a means to build
up the lamp push up because you can just
go as far as you need to you can also
alternatively start on your knees and
the other great thing about this of
course is that you're also working on
mobility as you try and get that nice
pancake stretch and bend straight down
to touch the ground
conversely if you want to make the la
land push up more difficult then the
obvious option to go with is to simply
perform it on a single hand this will
mean that you're lifting essentially
double the resistance on one side but at
the same time it has an anti-rotational
element because now your body wants to
twist down towards the side where the
arm is missing so you've got to brace
that way as well of course you can
remove fingers i mean not chop them off
just uh lift them up or fold them under
or if you're completely nuts you can
just add weight
so i hope you found this video useful
and interesting guys if you did then
please consider leaving a like and
sharing it around that helps me out
immensely what other cool exercises make
you feel like a badass if you did enjoy
this video then please leave a like and
share around that helps me out immensely
and if you enjoy this type of training
then check out my ebook and training
program super functional training 2.0
the protein performance system it also
comes with over two hours of video
tutorials and it includes the lan
push-up loads of progressions building
up to it lots of other similar exercises
that a little bit more out there and
build things that go beyond just
aesthetics and strength on a few lifts
either way thank you so much for
watching this one guys and i'll see you
next time bye for now